nathan it's so good to see you again man
it's crazy to think how much
has happened to you since that tick tock
video went viral
[Music]
you got engaged since i last saw you so
congratulations
um thank you how'd you pop the question
i was at las vegas
in a hotel and i kind of had to just do
it you know
in the elevator right when we got on top
of the
top floor where we were where we were at
and i stopped in the middle
and i played the song uh i want to grow
old with you
with by adam sandler
i tried to sing it in spanish and
yeah it didn't work but she kind of
helped me out with singing it and
everything finished it off
and at the end we ended up just yeah i
asked her she said yeah
and closed it out i love that we could
see your fiance in the background right
there
congratulations thank you
are you so happy yeah
did he do good can we see the ring
oh i'm blind and i'm kidding
wow it's gorgeous congratulations um
have you started planning the wedding
yet yeah we're
planning for august 2nd but we're not
sure right now
so you proposed in vegas
is there a good chance you guys might
get married in vegas like what are the
wedding plans like
no we're gonna do an idaho hometown
because that's where we're from most
times there everybody can't
you know fly or do anything like that
yeah so
we're just going to keep it home based
and just hopefully everybody gets to
show up there you know what i mean
i love that man well it sounds like your
wedding guest list could be pretty
stacked because
you have so many famous friends now
among them snoop dogg you guys got to do
a commercial together i mean
are you just homies now no it's not like
i have everybody on speed down nothing
like that you know what i mean
i still just do me you know what i mean
i don't call or bug any of them they
don't
you know it's not like i have their
numbers or anything like that you know
it's just
they are good acquaintances right now
and like i said no doubt yeah
listen you still got to hang out with
snoop dogg for a day i mean what was
that like
it was awesome i got to smoke with him
you know i got the smoke with wiz
khalifa
you know burner it's just you know and i
got to kick it with g-eazy
it's just it's just crazy stuff you know
what i mean between you snoop
and wiz who could smoke who under the
table though
uh they always say it's between them too
they say snoop always has it now are you
sipping cranberry juice are you sipping
gin and juice
i'm sipping cranberry with some gin and
juice nowadays
your juice of choice is cranberry juice
i love it
exactly uh so which celeb have you been
most star struck by or maybe the most
surprised
to learn was a fan of yours or recreated
your video
uh the best recreation of the video had
to be when
i seen jimmy fallon do it it just made
me laugh i don't know why it was just
simple and
plain and yeah it just made me laugh i
mean so many people have recraved your
video
including me dog okay i was you for
halloween
yeah that's what's up i was just told
today by three different people the same
thing they said yo i dressed up to you
as halloween
and i was like hey that's cool man do
you feel at all like overwhelmed by all
of this fame or is it something where
you're just
literally riding the wave and enjoying
it
i still feel the same you know what i
mean and it's not overwhelming to be in
and it got kind of overwhelming just
being on the phone constantly i feel
like i said just like a regular person
still i try to just go shop and do
whatever like i usually did you know
it's just now i get stopped to take
pictures and you know i ain't nobody
special you know like i
say all the time you know it's just me
doing me and i'm glad everybody lets me
still go out and just shop
you know and just have fun when they see
me i'll take a picture and
then let me go on my way you know what i
mean it's awesome it's fun and also
like i said just great vibes too we need
it this year um
you know the weekend i saw reposted a
video of you spoken to his song
which that was dope he's headlined in
the super bowl halftime show so i wanted
to ask you
what are the chances that we could see
you pop up at the super bowl in some
capacity like
maybe a commercial is there a commercial
in the works hey you know what i mean
who knows that's what i'm saying let's
get that out there
if it ain't out there already somewhere
in the in the mix you know because yeah
that would be awesome you know dream
come true beyond anything
you know especially with the weekend you
know doing it you know
and yeah that'd be crazy all right so
when we last spoke you told me that you
were hoping to buy a house and you did
what does it feel like to be a homeowner
it's awesome you know what i mean it
just feels weird that i have you know
living space of my own you know what i
mean and with my kids and everybody
with my with my wife now you know and
her son
we're steady steady vibing you know what
i mean we're just chilling
living life right now and trying to get
settled in we still haven't got anything
settled in because i'm still out here
working and moving
so yeah hopefully during these holidays
we get some
chill time to just get everything inside
and you know more settled
what would you tell 2019 nathan about
2020 nathan and what are you looking
forward to next year
i just tell everybody before you know
just
keep those close to you know what i mean
and remember all the good times and just
live life and have fun you know and be
safe
and then for 2021 i just want everybody
just to remember
everything you know what i mean just
like i said everybody thinks the year is
going to change everything it's just a
number you know but still
just live life and let's get over this
together you know
let's do what we need to do to get past
this
little pandemic so we can go back to
where we was you know what i mean
i love that man and keep making us laugh
keep entertaining us and i'm really
banking on seeing you super bowl sunday
okay
oh yes we'll do and let's let's hope for
that